I think everything's about balance like
I don't I don't think you know it just
balances
if if you're complaining like like the
one thing I want to make sure everybody
hears on the way to you know to work
today is if you make 41 thousand dollars
a year if you make 27 dollars an hour
and you work two jobs and you have four
hundred thousand dollars in student
loans but you don't complain and you're
not depressed
you've won if I can get one person right
now in the Mass Pike to do it and get
that email in two years then this ten
minutes was accomplished basically [ __ ]
rich a real pleasure your phone's dead
yeah my phone's that actually drain let
me call you back
Breakfast Club
yeah you do you I'm not judging who the
hell am I to judge here's what I'm
saying
you get one life hmm you've got real
like this is America and by the way I'm
not naive to like females race things
like that it's it's harder but if
there's anybody on earth that looks like
you that's made it that means you can do
it I'm gonna I'm gonna hook you up man
really hook you of course what's up
what's your email Richard you know I'll
let you put it in
so it will ring here I've a meeting
without a chase how about you you work
here yeah work here pleasure man
thanks for saying hello take care
Hey okay I gotta run into a meeting
I'm telling you no I think what I'm good
at is telling you when when things are
important so all right I'm gonna go in I
don't think you'll go up there
hey I am hey Jeremy Herbert hey Jay I'm
not work for a Barclays center oh is
that right yes yes thank you man
thanks for saying hello oh well yeah
real good
running into a meeting okay take care
yourself stay well
Oh a lot going on huh yeah I'll be but
I'll be pop-out all right okay hello how
are you doing good so far a good day
just uh jamming meeting up the meeting
fun to be with our broker how are you
good
there's a shitload of people here just a
ton of P that's where Ron is right India
now a national legend but very much in
New York legend he was our weatherman
especially for me growing up my sister
literally texted me she's like oh my god
al and so it was fun going to see my
grandma out on her birthday
my Esther it's exciting but do I think
you're poor or common I know there's
jamming just jamming so Jersey come back
bunch more meetings nothing too crazy
nothing to uh I don't know if we're
gonna do a big rant here that's gonna be
the whole show there should be more of a
day and day out kind of thing um but I
do think looking at the schedule we'll
have to come up with something smart and
awesome to to save you guys so hopefully
I'll get inspired at some point I think
I started thinking I was different it
was a couple of different times I think
I thought it was different in sixth
grade I remember very clearly thick
fifth grade fifth sixth grade whatever
that is how do you build unbelievable
self esteem without creating any
entitlement
I mean [ __ ] that's what it is
that's what it is yeah like I am
completely egotistical about my skills
with zero entitlement it's why I have
special results because I'm point of so
opposite you know like I think like I if
you ask me if I gave my best at-bat of
dissecting why I've over indexed it or
success it's because I'm pulling from
very opposite points of view and it's
creating enormous balance no one side
gets ahead of the other side like like
my Klinko and my bravado allow me not to
just do the humility get the dirt work
stuff it's why I don't have like a
garage sale business but my my lack of
entitlement and humility allow me not to
like read the accolades and when people
say I'm the best or a top five or the
future of this like I'm like I don't
deserve that
I need to earn that yes I do a daily
vlog so I'm documenting my entire life
forever if I actually from where I
started go on to buy a four billion
dollar sports organization and I
documented the entire journey my words
are motivating and I'm good at that
but the reason I knew dailyvee and the
reason I'm documenting so much is if I
can put out a body of work 40 years from
now that showed the process of a young
man that put in the work had the vision
did it the right way try to help people
along the way because he was trying to
build the biggest building in town by
building it not by tearing everybody
else's buildings down and then I
actually accomplished it well that
becomes a real a real a real great
American dream story that becomes a
movie that becomes legacy that becomes
all-time special and I'm not gonna
become a billionaire overnight like
sucks or like Sokka or like Travis but
I'm gonna get there as a tortoise which
is going to confuse everybody because I
have a hares costume good fun meaning
that's bad no game good
good meeting yes welcome to Sunday
school I gotta go hey I hope everybody's
doing super well and happy and super
available if you need me and I you know
being a good Jersey boy like I watched
out given the weather like when I was
like six so it's like super glad I'm
like of course I didn't follow the
script what's up guys story I didn't
listen it then we're we getting in a cab
okay
Toyota Camry what what's the digits
silver T six where is he talent gets you
so far putting in the work like a lot of
people look at finished products they
look at LeBron today then look at Kobe
today they look at Beyonce today you
know what's great about some of the old
some of the way certain people worked
Beyonce's a good play her family wanted
thought that she would be a star they
would be stars so there's a lot of film
of them on Star Search or the old video
cameras but that was work when she was a
young teenager like maybe even before
she was a teenager she's learning dance
and it was like you know now people see
like we'll listen to a song where she
has a lot of bravado and I go hey no
it's very you know it's it's a lot
easier to to do it you know to be
somebody who's got confidence or own
or is looking for something that may
seem you know disproportionate because
they know the 40 years they put into
this is look at the complete debacle
it's no sense if I'm sitting on a couch
and I'm like oh that athlete thinks
they're so fancy I wasn't there for the
last 22 years that they woke up at 5
o'clock in the morning to get them from
this moment and that's cut and it's
probably how I feel a lot which is like
I get that like everybody shouldn't
almost specially the way I communicate
and how competitive I am almost
everybody should be like who do you
think you are but I also know why I feel
like I can do that because I only give
advice I take for myself I lack any
hypocrisy I'm telling you things that I
do for myself I telling you to be
patient I'm patient you're just catching
me at 40 catch me at 22 when I'm bagging
nice catch me at 25 years old when I'm
already got stuff going on and I'm
carrying the boxes really easy for me to
tell you like be patient you know like
or anybody you know like like I'm not
talking about what we just talked about
I'm talking about anybody because when I
was 27 years old and already built a big
business and like I already had a real
success and could have taken a lot of
money off the table I on December 9th
would carry your box for you know three
boxes of beer to your car and say thank
you for shopping at the store and we and
like like nothing was beloved today
nothing is below me
you know
I'm out of here see timestamp that
[Applause]